[MUSIC]
I'm going to try something
a little different.
I'm going to tell you a story, but
it's a different kind of story.
It's very short,
it only has three sentences.
Are you ready?
>> Yes.
>> Thanks, Jake.
He went to the store.
Fred died.
Sharon went hungry and wept.
Now, in listening to this story,
what can you all tell me about maybe
the relationship between Fred and Sharon?
Any ideas?
Does anybody think they were married?
Ted Ming, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> So
did you think that Fred was the one
who went to the grocery store?
And you also thought that the store
that Fred was going to was a grocery
store, right?
So in looking at this story,
I didn't actually say any of that.
In these three simple sentences,
Ted interpreted some things
that weren't necessarily there.
Now, our brains are actually
hardwired to do this.
Now imagine that you're trying to convince
someone of your side of an argument,
or trying to explain something,
some concept to somebody.
People may be interpreting things
that aren’t necessarily there.
So what’s going on here?
What can science tell us about how we’re
interpreting this information, and
how can we use that information
to tell better stories?
>> Our brains are pre-disposed to think
in story terms and in story structures.
This impacts how we understand things,
how we make sense of things, and
what we choose to remember and
what we choose to forget.
These story terms and structures,
they provide a sense of order
to information that's coming to
us that's otherwise disorderly.
Now Kendall Haven and his team of
researchers, who are the leading
researchers on this topic,
they've done an extensive amount of work.
And they've found that this story-like
structure that our brains are so
accustomed to, they're the result
of over 100,000 years of evolution.
They've also found the specific
part of our brain that's in charge
of applying this story-like structure,
it's called the Neural Story Net.
And the neural story net has
one very important goal.
It needs to satisfy
the Make Sense Mandate of our brains.
So what is the Make Sense Mandate?
It's very simple, actually.
It just says that everything we see and
hear needs to make sense before we
actually understand and learn it.
It's pretty simple, right?
Things just need to make
sense before we learn it.
But what's more interesting to
observe is how our neural story net
impacts the information that we're
receiving if it's disorderly.
How does it manipulate information that's
told to us in order to force it to
make sense?
Let's take Dillon's example.
He gave you three sentences,
completely disjointed and disorganized.
Your neural story nets started making
certain assumptions about those
three sentences in order to
make it make sense to you.
He went to the store.
Fred died.
Sharon went hungry and wept.
You made the assumption that Fred and
Sharon were married.
You made the assumption that
the story was a grocery store.
Dillon didn't actually say any of that,
but you assumed it.
That's your neural story net in action.
That's it working to try to bring
some connection between these
disjointed sentences.
Now it can get worse than this.
If the story being told to you is so
disjointed, if it's so disorganized,
your brain may have to work so hard that
it just decides, hey, let's disengage.
Let's forget about what's
being told to us right now.
It might tell your body to
slouch back in your chair.
It might tell your hand to reach into
your pocket, pull out your iPhone,
you just play around on it and
forget about it, forget about class.
Now look, that's all well and good if
we're the listeners in the audience.
If we're the listeners, sure, we can just
store some information, we can make some
assumptions, can maybe just forget about
things and play back on our iPhones.
But what if we're the communicators?
What if we're the ones who
need to send some very important
message to the audience?
What if we have a crucial message and
we can't let the audience disengage?
We can't let them distort our information.
If that's the case,
then we need some sort of strategy.
We need to come up with something
to be able to fit our message into
a story-like structure.
Because it's your job, as storytellers,
to connect all the dots for your audience.
So Kendall Haven, in all his research,
he's come up with four major concepts
which govern how well a message is
delivered and whether that delivery
fits into the story-like structure
that our brains are accustomed to.
So let's learn about those
four major concepts.
>> The four concepts are rooted in one
belief, and that is the listener's ability
to make sense of our story, directly
impact our ability to influence them.
So the first step, engagement.
Now engagement does not necessarily
guarantee influence automatically, but
it is certainly the first
step to making it possible.
So what is engagement?
Engagement is our ability
to physically show up.
It's our intentive focus on making sure
that when we're connecting with our
listeners and
we're physically being engaged with them.
No matter how complex and
nuanced the story is,
to no matter how simple the story is,
like Dylan's three-sentence story.
What we've learned in class is that there
are a couple of different ways in which we
can actually, physically engage.
Through the Use of Pauses,
our Tone of Voice, our Hand Gesturing,
our Eye Contact, and our Posture.
Transportation, what
we learned from the neural story net is
that listeners are constantly trying to
figure out what information we need to
throw away and what information we need
to keep to actually make sense
of a story being told to us.
What transportation enables
us to do as storytellers,
what you as storytellers,
is it helps a listener visualize and
contextualize the story and
the plot line that they're being put into.
And that can happen in various formats.
In class, we learn through visual
word plays as one example.
To even Mark Bezos physically,
overtly, bringing us and
transporting us into his storyline
as a firefighter in his TED talk.
Ultimately, transportation
is aimed at building trust
between the story, the storyteller and
the narrative being told.
So with engagement, with transportation,
Ash will speak a bit more about how to
deliver content that is influencing.
>> So
the third point in this is relevance.
It is self-explanatory.
As Judy says there's aim,
understand your audience,
design your intent and
narrate your message accordingly.
So your content has to be
relevant to your audience
because our mind has a make sense mandate.
Our mind is constantly asking this
question, what's in it for me?
How am I related to this story?
If there is no connection, the mind
can outrightly reject your message,
and do something as Jeff said, play with
the mobile phone or completely disconnect.
But if you can make sense
with your audience,
if you can stay relevant to your audience,
you can completely sell your idea.
The fourth is influence.
This is the whole purpose of your message.
This is what you're trying
to do with your story.
You want to influence their behavior.
You want to make your audience do certain
things in the way you want them to do.
But is it the only behavior
that we want to address?
Probably not.
Behavior is only a manifestation.
We want to address their attitudes.
We want to address their beliefs,
their knowledge.
We want to alter that.
We want to create a parallel
stream of their beliefs.
Okay, what you're saying,
what you're thinking is right, but
let us think it this way.
Do not try to correct that.
Do not try to say, no, what you're saying
is wrong, what I'm saying is right.
That doesn't sell, no.
You have to alter it,
you have to define a new balance tree.
In summary,
we talked about three things today.
Our brain analyzes every
message in story form.
If it cannot connect with a story,
our message does not pass through.
Number one message.
Number two,
based on if our idea makes sense,
based on the make sense mandate in our
brain, our message can be accepted,
altered or
completely rejected by our audience.
And third, we can craft good
stories if we follow a structure.
If we can stay engaged,
if we can transport our audience to
the place where we want to take them,
it stays relevant and influence their
attitude, belief and knowledge.
We can craft excellent stories
that can influence our audience.
Thank you.
[MUSIC]